Ken are you interested in spending a
million dollars
it sounded like a no what are you doing
why live in a house when you can live in
car
for a million dollars wow what a deal is
it that bad a million dollars to live in
a bus yes fast man you're right you're
pretty bad
well we'll see maybe this will change
your mind because we're touring the most
futuristic motorhome in the world
this one's actually cool I've seen bids
luxurious motorhome built by dumbbell
and on the back we have a full-size
garage so you can pick your personal car
bruh it has a car inside the car and
inside that car is another
oh my gosh I love the full-size garage
they got like the mini fitting in there
it's cool though
kind of cool yeah
yeah trailer or whatever or the little
thing where you like tie it to the back
of the motorhome or whatever it
isn't that be easier it would it would
yeah but it's not as cool
I don't know if it's massive he barely
fits in the road
yeah this is gonna say yeah can you
actually drive that on roads it's bigger
than buses
it looks like it takes the entire Road
here I think it does well that's the
thing though like you've driven bigger
vehicles right yeah yeah yeah you're
American of course but if you have a big
car you'd think it's like oh no I have
to like be so careful it's the opposite
it's like you you you stick out
of my way I'm driving a one million
dollar bus
oh man that reminds me you know
sometimes people tail it tailgate you is
that what it's called yeah and you kind
of feel bad because you're like oh I
should just probably speed up but you
don't really want it at some point right
and I always feel like all right what do
you want and then you look behind you
and there's like three cars and you're
like but if you have a big vehicle I
don't give a for some reason
whenever I drove like bands and stuff
like that big line I'm like all right
too bad guys sorry yeah whatever you
look back like looking over the top of
them what you do though Felix when you
like look into your rearview mirror and
all you can see is like the BMW symbol
and that's it and they're like right on
your tail slam your brakes real quick
and collect some insurance money easy
got it yeah I made all my money
it comes out uh missiles
[Laughter]
someone going too slow
[Music]
so fancy well look how tiny the
registers
because binoculars out and he can see
the next town over
the grill looks so mean too it's like a
like a yeah
first thing I want to mention this
motorhome is built on a Mercedes actress
chassis you have a 12.8 liter engine V12
that gets 530 horsepower and check this
out Mikey this vehicle does 11 and a
half miles per gallon even though it
weighs 26 tons is that good can I don't
know
I mean maybe for the size of that thing
it's great but you know you're not going
very far you're not going yeah you're
gonna be paying so much in gas golly
fill that thing up ridiculous that's
crazy what a Hummer does eight or nine
miles a gallon right that's right so I'm
compared to a Hummer the worst gas
mileage in the history of any car you're
going to compared to that yeah sit in
the bar low wow
it's just the motorhome looks so modern
and elegant and we're used to seeing a
lot of motorhomes that are a little bit
more let's say old school air
conditioners I think so
the thing looks like any motorhome I've
ever seen they all look like boats
stupid
things here and check this out it's so
elevated from the ground look at it it's
higher than him
ridiculous like finding a ladder to get
up exactly but God damn you're gonna
jump down from there it's like rainy
outside and you slip you better bring
your parachute because you're falling
you're like three cars High I just
imagine like you slip and you fall and
like plays like the sad music but it
just you just fall for so long
[Laughter]
side mirrors it has side cameras and
we're going to show you guys how that
works there's a mirror right beside that
what do you mean oh yeah you're right
this is so wide that it can't even fit
side mirrors that's literally the reason
like yeah yeah you're right yeah
probably 100 right slide out here that
kicks out about 50 centimeters that's
your living room area and on this side
we have two folding chairs custom
designed for this motorhome where you
can store it right here that's your
storage compartment that connects all
the way to Bam look at all that storage
wow
below here Mikey we have your hydraulic
pumps and right next to that is your
split air conditioning unit for the
entire motorhome super cool only thing
that this thing makes me think of is the
maintenance is going to be insane
one thing breaks and you're just oof and
finding a dude that knows how to work on
this thing right exactly that too yeah
there's a nice cutout for your keypad
and I cannot show you guys this code but
you can hide away your stairs that's
pretty cool come on that's amazing
hidden stairs I mean I was just thinking
about how hard he was having to push
those keys he was smacking that thing I
could hear it all the way in the camera
I was actually thinking if you live in
like
San Francisco or like somewhere really
expensive wouldn't you rather live in
this than like this little Loft that you
will get for that same price yeah right
I guess so yeah right maybe it's not
such a bad idea after all honestly
what's the generation after us because
they're gonna all live in motor homes or
I don't know what they're gonna do they
sorry you're screwed all of you we have
this motorized retractable awning system
with LED lighting on it looks cool super
unique yeah above that is obviously like
if someone gave me this I would take it
I'd be like cool thank you that's
awesome
I don't know what I'm gonna do with it
okay can't fit it anywhere literally
like like this imagine going to a
campsite with this thing like it
would be possible
out there you know in redneckville where
I live and like they're all out there
with the campers like hey Jimbo look at
that thing you can rolling up in your
Mercedes whatever this thing is rolling
it out it's like God damn
probably
shoot it I don't know what they'll do
they'd freak out and maybe in America it
would work but in the Europe I don't I
don't know I would not want to drive
this thing you just get robbed
in it no but this is there's folding can
what do you mean oh you're right
you're right three and a half meters in
depth and on top of that you have a
secondary motorized screen here
down below here and you don't want to
get the sun Oh I thought it was a
projector screen maybe it could be hmm
it looks translucent I don't think so
when the wind gets up to 39 kilometers
an hour it automatically closes up since
it doesn't have any supporting legs wow
super unique right no that's standard
with those I actually knew that because
I was gonna buy one not super unique
okay exactly 39 miles per hour
a Brisk Day in the UK it closes right
now every single today yes
this model has a small ridiculous smart
car which is incredible it's also
branded with the same color theme like
the rest of the motorhome
they come with this I think it does yeah
yeah okay or go to grocery shopping
exactly yeah and I would love go grocery
shopping with that thing
where would you feed your groceries in
that tiny little car it wouldn't fit
anything
oh my gone that's slow oh my God
oh my God I would never use that serial
killers after you you're gonna die Mikey
is over with
I want to briefly talk about the color
palette and kind of like the design
elements motor home they went with this
nice simple white color and that's the
signature dumbbell red and black
combination right there where we have
the glass panels can we see the
inside already Jesus Christ and down
below is your 408 kilowatt diesel
generator with a soundproof case there
that way when it turns on you don't even
hear it inside of the motorhome it has a
young vibe to it you have a Mercedes
chassis you can't really go wrong with
that a young Vibe you know there's
probably a lot of young people riding
this thing around I feel yeah lots of
young whippersnappers out there driving
this you're their wife angry that they
had to climb up all those Stairs
Of America soundproof you can't hear it
I can still hear the teacher January
he said it had a soundproof chassis but
then there's no cover on the bottom of
it it just come down at the bottom and I
can still hear it yeah
let's go to the game say so we can see
it enjoy the nature get in the town of
car we gotta go to the go get some gas
we gotta get some groceries
and it takes like four hours
I'll meet you guys inside
finally insane what are we guys are
worth it
and we go straight into the living room
area now the interior of this motorhome
is stunning that specializes in yacht
design and there that's it it's a yacht
yeah it's just making normal looking I
feel beautiful finishes with clad
details really shows in this interior
now the first area I want to cover is
right behind me we have this 50 inch TV
and this is your first slide out Mikey
you even have some upper cabinets here
of course you're built now I wonder what
it looks like when it's not slid out
like how much room do you have when it's
all in I thought it was it's not slid
out it's just a cozy area for you to sit
down and watch your TV since it's on a
perfect angle now in front of the
seating area we also have this table
that's currently positioned as a coffee
table and you can actually make it
adjust it turn it this way and have it
as a dining table as well on top of that
a lot of interesting features in this
thing correct
[Laughter]
30 more minutes this direction to your
seating area and obviously when you're
mixing things everyone should be
launched
but more importantly Mikey ready
I'm gonna you're gonna get crushed
normally you would have these chairs
leaning back so you can actually lower
this queen size bed all the way down
here and that's your additional for your
enemies there well your gentlemen smash
them sit down and buckle them
[Laughter]
the cockpit of this motorhome is truly
stunning you have so much space here and
visibility is great I'm currently
sitting in the driver's seat all these
seats that we're sitting on all four
seats they are heated cooled and
massaged massage while driving hush I
don't know oh my gosh it feels like
you're floating on these I mean it's
amazing I'm sure it's super fun to drive
this thing around and visibility is
great drive it then I want to see you
drive it it's so fun do it test drive
couldn't even say on their own come on I
want to see him drive it of course these
are soft clothes check this out they
have espresso cups branded with dumbbell
that's insane
incredible
wow this dishware everything is actually
branded in fact I'm gonna show more in a
bit down below the induction pulls down
pants
dishwasher drawer
dishwasher why is it like that that's so
cool you can just like
dude
that's so good I guess like one level
the dishwasher and instead of like two
like you usually get I'll take one level
if I can just throw it all in like it's
garbage
like I said we recognize The Branding oh
my gosh oh The Branding on the knife
I buy it now this cover plate comes off
and there you go you have your modern
sink there with a pop-up faucet
there you go okay that's a respectable
sink as a big fan of nice things it's
got a little in it that's so cool back
on another good thing show them where
the sink what the is it branded
though is it branded this thing I don't
think so and they even utilize spaces
like this one to create excess storage
in there
triangle shape you can only use like
part of it a couple spices there I guess
but yeah that's good Rich down below we
have the freezer
and that wraps our tour for the kitchen
now like the rest of the motorhome this
bag is that Japanese toilet I don't know
no signs with the curved walls LED lift
mirror what was wrong with the toilet
paper they came with the toilet paper on
the handle for a million dollars what is
it what is that it's just stuck in
between the toilet and the this is
inexcusable oh my God looks like they've
squished it as well
ridiculous I can't wipe with this it
doesn't roll properly anymore like reach
around my back to grab that too what is
this Mikey can you help me with these
Mikey what were they thinking but The
Branding on the on the towel there oh
yeah they should have branded the toilet
paper LED lit mirror here for your
makeup or when you get ready you need it
towel racks you can do your makeup over
the toilet and drop stuff in it yeah
that's great
[Laughter]
they have them everywhere in the UK but
that that's like cool it's a little
hotter than normal yeah you put it down
and you're like oh warm but then it's
instantly cold exactly it's not like it
doesn't no it doesn't work put a massive
rain head above even your shower head is
actually a good size yeah and it's not
small in there either go go inside
you're drown that thing the shower heads
like the same size of the hole
that you have an LED lighter yeah when
they thought about it everything and
last part Mikey this door right here
opens up to your closet for your
bathroom and down below you have a
washer and dryer which is something you
gotta have now at the end of this
hallway we got to show this detail
remedicio mirror pocketing door it's
mirror because you can actually see
yourself it's like a nice full-size
mirror that closes off your bedroom
Mikey come on hating that's cool this
space is just as cozy as the rest of the
motor home I love the mood lighting that
they have throughout around the bed
setup you have two massive windows on
each side bringing now that's a nice TV
right there you need it and of course
you have your bug screen automatic
Shades black house everything you need
making just like the Yachts that we've
been seeing they have the same stainless
steel reveal detail around this window
opening that looks Exquisite dude how
many do they have back there Jesus
Christ
oh all of them no one's bought one yet
like I like it I'm not hating on it a
little bit but like what would you use
what I don't get it I don't get it maybe
you're traveling cross country or
something but then you get a tour bus
now is this a tour bus what is it it's a
really nice tour bus yeah but it's
clearly like built as a camping bus with
like the cover yeah yeah using this in
Germany Europe would be quite
interesting because most companies won't
allow such a big buzz or even on the
streets like yeah it's it doesn't make
sense all right Ken are you sold one
million dollars one wow I need two of
them please you give one America's one
yep let's go on a tour honey yeah you
drive yours I drive mine yeah
that's not too bad though it's kind of
cool if I had a million dollars to burn
maybe that'd be something I consider
when I'm you know but no that's thing
though like why
'd you buy it okay
but I don't get it it's gonna be a
market for it though they made it and
it's they making a lot of that there's
no market for it dude like this YouTube
video If you enjoyed smash like And
subscribe check out Ken and see you in
the next one bye bye let me just try
something first
hi everyone and welcome back to our
Channel today we're talking about online
privacy and security which is a critical
issue in today's digital world
as you all know the internet can be a
dangerous place it's important to have
protection when browsing online that's
why we're so excited to have nordvpn as
our sponsor for this segment logo with
animation into music
nordvpn is the world's leading VPN
provider eh so I've cut to nordvpnm
animation with information about their
features if you're ready to take your
online privacy and security to the next
level then head over to nordvpn.com and
get started today trust us you won't
regret it uh play the outro music and
animation side and a call out to action
to visit nordvpn.com that was actually
pretty good all that other side
I I love using VPN you guys know nordvpn
and if you switch the end with the p I'm
not going to say anything else
neural VPN is also celebrating their
11th birthday I don't know why I did it
too and if you sign up with the link in
the description you have a chance to win
one additional year for free
but everyone that signs up will get a
huge discount on a two-year deal that's
where it came in plus additional gift
if you sign up for a new special time
you can get an additional four months
for free that's not vpn.com PewDiePie
click the link say thanks